by the way what's the story what
happened with fauci and uh rand paul can
you pull up that story for us to read it
you talking about it at dinner last
night it came out i believe it was the
intercept that fauci apparently had uh
he lied again completely lied in which
under oath in congress light again yeah
the last time that that he came out uh
it's it's moments like this where i do
wish the mob was kind of still involved
in our government to be honest with you
too uh rand paul says the new warhand
documents show out you like can you go
up a little bit to sifa okay here
general zones in the big public
documents revealing the extent of u.s
funding coronavirus recently rohan shows
the national institute of allergy and
infectious disease had anthony fauci
lied during his previous testimony to
congress fouchen has adamantly denied
that the national institute of health
funded gain of function research and
wuhan paul blasted fauci in a tuesday
tweet saying that the naid director had
lied again and i was right about his
agency funding novel corona virus
research at wuhan said rand paul go up a
little bit because of tweets down here
uh rand paul tweet
surprise surprise fauci lied again and i
was right about his agency funding novel
coronavirus research at warren read this
thread and the papers released can you
click on that just to see what that is
it made a formal request to the justice
department to open an investigation
let's read this let's read this so newly
released documents provide detail of u.s
funded research on coronavirus at the
one and survivorology the intercept has
obtained more than 900 pages of document
detailing work of eco-health alliance at
the chinese lab
the trove of documents includes two
previously unpublished grant proposals
that were funded by the niaid
as well as the project updates relating
to equal health alliance research which
is scrutinized aimed increased interest
in
materials show toners for 10 hours on
and then contracts understand no terms
and forms of grants reinsurance the
materials revealed that the resulting
novel laboratory generates sars related
coronavirus also could infect mice
engineer to display human receptors on
cells
interesting
so what's going to happen now because
yesterday somebody asked jen saki she
just walked on that's the thing you you
asked this question to rudy it was one
of the best questions you would ask you
said if you know these guys
are are corrupt and you have the
evidence
all it takes is for one of them to crack
you just need one of them to crack and
the rest of them will fall why why why
is it how how come you know you talked
about omerta how is it that these guys
nobody talks over there and what he says
is that nobody's threatening him so the
mafia never talked until he took all
their stuff away the racketeering act
you take somebody and you put them in a
large conspiracy and say hey you may not
have done uh all this but you're
attached to the guys who did all this
and are you going to go away for them
but you're right aren't you seeing
what's happening here trump gets
impeached for a phone call that he made
okay that wasn't anywhere near as
disastrous as the phone call that biden
made to the president of afghanistan and
asked him to lie
straight out lied to the world
and what happens
cricket's out of pelosi nobody wants to
say anything this is such a corrupt
system right now
it's such a double standard that we have
it's disgusting i can't even believe it
if you and i were to do something like
that we'd be doing 100 years
it's terrible what's happening in this
country do you think politicians on both
sides lie
absolutely okay so so let's let's put
that side aside meaning you know uh the
left's gonna lie the right's gonna lie
okay and the left is always gonna show
the one tweeter this guy was lying and
the right is gonna say this guy was
lying okay fine
so
let's say
uh oh oh there is a
sinners on both sides and you know the
saying people sin in different ways okay
this is where i'm going with this
put that aside
if a person is leading an army if a
person is leading a country if a person
is leading a family
okay if a person is like hey where were
you you know i was with my friends
okay and we were watching the game hey
what were you doing
what is the core
need a country
demands from their leader
forget about the lying part i don't
think we've had a president that hasn't
lied yet okay left right middle doesn't
matter right
so so number one is safety right okay
great would you agree with that safety
is number one keep the country safe okay
so i don't care what you're saying
what's your spew now because sometimes
you know we have pride we're like well
you know no no no no no maybe over
exaggerated you know i don't think
anybody's going to be uh innocent of
that right okay
are we getting safety what's next out of
safety i would say justice
okay so justice fine what is after
justice so justice is a form of safety
to me by the way because justice
provides me to know that a bigger guy is
not going to bully me because i know law
and order is going to protect that's
something i got to be honest with you
i've lost faith in over the last 10
years i do not believe we are all
operating under the same set of rules i
i think somebody your political
affiliation
is going to determine whether you're
innocent or guilty not the actual
committing of the crime how can you hold
one party accountable to one person
accountable to something and let the
other one go with the same crime
you know patrick this country is going
crazy i am a former criminal
do you know that in san francisco now
they are paying criminals not to shoot
other people what i don't pay their
money 300 bucks
yeah but that's not new what's going on
in san francisco
how long that's where nancy pelosi and
kamala harris are from and dianne
feinstein three of the most powerful
people in our government are from san
francisco that's their home
one of the greatest cities in the world
what i'm saying i use the biden trump
thing because how could you hold
somebody
so accountable for something that they
did and somebody did something even more
grievous and you just crickets you let
it go yeah what's going on in this
country is the double standard is
horrible the justice department can't be
politicized man it just can't be it is
it is 100 percent and
again bring this up i and i don't care
who it is hunter biden's laptop
draw it if you and i had information
just the stuff that we've heard forget
about what else might be on there we
would be doing a hundred year you would
be in jail with no bail you'd be doing a
hundred years
too and everybody forgets about that one
well i mean
this is the president's son who was
using his father's political power to
ingratiate himself into and i mean you
ca and it's right out in the open has it
been going on of course but this is
right out in the open you have to act on
stuff like this
and they're letting it go otherwise
people who's letting it go
in your opinion what what do you think
they should do and i'm not a hunter
biden fan i just
it's not like it's not in the news it's
not like they can't go after them you
should do something about it obviously
justice joe biden's not going to do
anything about it the justice department
okay
by the democrats we talk about we talk
about january 6th and how serious that
was and that there was a january january
6th commission
there were hundreds of riots where
people actually died billions of dollars
of damage you know they take over
portland they take over the city of
portland america you know nothing's done
you know what the biggest insult and
slap in the face i don't know if you've
watched uh you know the recent thing on
9 11 the documentary with uh condoleezza
rice and all those guys yeah all of that
what do you think about it i thought it
was great okay what's his name the uh
the black film producer uh did it what's
your tyler perry no not time likely
spike lee spike
it's brill yeah you got to watch it it's
it'll make it
is it one-sided or no no it'll make you
cry he did a brilliant job okay
but no no here's the thing yeah
yeah
we all remember the devastation of that
day we all remember no question there
was nothing like it ever in our lifetime
for these people aoc and some of these
people to compare what happened on
january 6
to what happened on 9 11 is is the most
disgusting thing i have ever heard 3 000
lives lost a city the worst thing that
ever happened compared you know other
than
pearl harbor and that was at least all
military and for them to say that
january 6th was worse than 9 11
a.o.c
they're treating it worse than what yes
and pelosi these people just say these
things are not not held accountable to
it
it's an insult to everybody whatever
side you're on the aisle that's just
doesn't matter what yeah it doesn't it's
not dumb it's not dumb it's worse than
dome
you don't see you know when it's so dark
dark and divisive and it's offensive i
would put all of that and she lives in
new york
yeah but you have to realize again
respect the the enemy has to get respect
for her knowing how to move
naive people who
are looking to find a person that they
hate because of whatever reasons right
like
one of the guys i'm interviewing right
now that we put on the list yesterday
you know he again another guy that's a
communist who hates capitalism because
capitalists make a lot of money and it's
not fair i'm like i can't wait to talk
to guys like this these are the types of
guys i want to talk to
they're convincing
they get people to say this makes sense
like aoc is very very convincing
she's got you know you have to know i'm
telling you right now there's a 10 to 20
chance aoc is going to be president
united states one day 10 to 20 uh
you're saying lower or higher
oh my god
lower or higher please be lower okay i'm
willing to bet i'm willing to bet right
now she stays alive she stays healthy
i'm willing to bet she's going to be a
president she's got another 40 years
let me tell you she's doing something
that roger stone said the most important
thing for somebody to be a real
candidate is what relevance is relevancy
and eyeballs yeah he's by the way like
logan paul that's a qualified guy that
could be a president next 20 years you
can hate logan paul all you want that
guy is going to be a candidate to run
for president compete with xi jinping
well it's like who's the girl that you
even brought up her name the girl the
governor of uh christine okay never
heard of her we talked politics all day
long i've never heard her name she's
amazing she says never heard her name
zero relevancy so we've all heard of
yeah you
know i'm getting easier and easier to to
be sold on joe manchin joe manchin is
doing doing something i've been calling
for john he's going to run i don't know
if he's going to run i don't think
that's in his uh he should though i
don't think he's going to run so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]